tuberculosis is the world's leading
infectious disease killer it's not covet
it was in 2020 and 2021 right but even
in 2022 it was not tuberculosis is a
killer that we don't even think about
anymore in the rich World it used to
kill a lot of us it's tuberculosis over
the last 200 years probably killed about
a billion people so everyone you know
now that's not true but a fourth of
everyone you knew in the 1800s died from
killed Doc Holiday we all know that if
you if you watch Wyatt Earp and Young
Guns well there you go yeah and yeah and
it was a disease but then came a
peninsulin and we basically got rid of
it you know we got we knew how to fix it
and it's not been a problem in rich
countries it still is a huge problem so
it kills 1.4 million people in the poor
part of the world